accueillons maintenant miss meurthe et
boulettes bull à martigues où la n va
bien et très belle en blonde tu ne vas
pas ce que tu es là je te jure il se
régale et c'est vrai tu es très belle en
dirais très franchement la malibu ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais non mais la
belle benhaim elles sortent des vannes
de 1972 sur louis allard ta manif d
arlette à malibu et puis si on regarde
du côté d'oriens un ton un peu je vais
te dire ça commence avec moi elle fait à
l'aide de mon fils tu vas rencontrer
maman sortie estivale fès orthez b les
tumeurs benhaim alors bénin
benhaim demain il n'y aura pas de chez
que de la télé il n'y aura pas tpm des
sortes et 5 minutes vous faites le temps
lachance sorte mais naïve alors venez
alors benhaim et je tiens à teaneck
avait déjà offert un cadeau oui mais on
s'en fout sa deuxième cadeau fiscal m'a
ouvert allons faire une bague dans ma
loge la dernière fois tu vois tout le
match ce n'est fait exprès
[Musique]
alors par contre j'adore mais sont les
pires elles sont attendues mais je vous
les aidant je sais vraiment pas au cumin
et les effets de mai alors est-ce que
vous pouvez les rails une alim gens
ayant lu quoi un rien puisqu'on apprend
même de ses erreurs donc il faut voilà
prévenus merci la catéchèse
non mais malheureusement toi c'est pas
le cas tu as fait un paquet d'erreurs et
a rien appris
ça y est l'adage alors attention là
c'est très simple où ça s'ouvre et c'est
bon ou bien c'est qu'il ya un problème
[Applaudissements]
on va juste juste soit le tiers de mes
fans
cette pauvre ben haim le tir même de ma
de ma carrière ah ouais vas regardera le
caducée pasqua entière de ouf je suis
pas sûr
[Applaudissements]
ce soir c'est une émission c voilà j'ai
envie de dire ça y est là on a envie de
se détendre
autant dax on était tendue comme des
sprints de plus des semaines et des
semaines
non jean rendez vous moi j'aimais déjà
entendu comme un arrêt vous jure kwabena
et moi j'étais tendu
vous étiez tendu vous moi j'étais dans
la quête jamais tendu oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça se voit que vous me
connaissez pas mais c'était moi vous
êtes qui est ce que vous allez faire des
commentaires tout cela et vous avez vous
lu que soit la loge alors plus
aujourd'hui à leur place number one way
est d'ailleurs de toutes les façons ou
ne l'arrête le plus alors vous je vous
le dis et je suis pas le seul à le dire
il ya plein de gens qui disent que vous
avez pris la grosse tête daniel il a
mauvais coton je vous lis et benhaim moi
je vais dégonfler tout ça et tu sais
quoi quoi redescendre salle en panne en
la pagani ses portes les sorties n'en
menaient pas gagné et bien et je vous le
dis vous ne revenez pas donc vous n'avez
pas débouler